provisions nicolas très simplement
qu'elle tombe manteau terrestre
et bien si on regarde les sections dans
le globe terrestre comme celle ci on va
appeler manteau terrestre toute cette
zone en noir c'est à dire que ghosn qui
s'étend entre le noyau en rouge et les
corses terrestre les corses et d'une
pellicule qui à trente kilomètres
d'épaisseur donc largement exagéré sur
cette coupe et le manteau donc arrive à
30 depuis trente mètres sous la surface
jusqu'à 2009 100 km le noyau ensuite va
de 2009 sans insigne km qui est là la
dimension du rayon terrestre
en particulier si on prend un
échantillon de ces roches du manteau on
antilles - extrait une carotte
on va disposer cette carotte au sein
d'un assemblage en céramique
lequel prend place vous le voyez ici
dans cette cylindrée t et l'échantillon
dans bien sûr et grâce à un piston on va
pouvoir exercer une pression qui va
correspondre à une profondeur allant
jusqu'à 75 km il ya un four interne qui
permet de chauffer l'échantillon et par
conséquent d'atteindre des températures
allant jusqu'à 1 500 degrés même plus
éventuellement c'est à dire celles qui
règnent dans le ventre intéressés enfin
dernière leur performance unique c'est
que on peut simultanément grâce ce type
east ont déformé l'échantillon en
appuyant dessus voyez il y stocker le
premier de la sorte nous réalisons des
déformations qui sont à peu près
comparable à celle qui se produit dans
le manteau en vison nicolas quelles sont
les conclusions pratiques sur
l'évolution de la terre que vous tirez
vos expériences et bien on peut dire que
les sciences de la terre ont vécu depuis
une dizaine d'années une véritable
révolution en ce sens que maintenant
tout le monde admet la théorie de la
dérive des continents la technique
globale c'est à dire qu'à partir de
rides océaniques comme celle qui court
au mieux l'atlantique les continents ces
cartes progressivement avec eux
ici l'amérique s'emboîtent très bien
dans la flic
la question qu'on se pose maintenant je
me tourne vers tableau c'est celle de
savoir comment et pourquoi ces
continents se déplace eh bien ça c'est
dû à des mouvements dans le manteau des
mouvements sein du manteau le manteau se
déforme et c'est là où notre appareil
prend son intérêt grâce à cet appareil
nous pouvons laboratoire étudier les
déformations qui se produisent dans le
manteau et par conséquent comprendre le
moteur est il finalement la façon de
façon plus précise la façon dont ces
plaques pendant dont la croûte se
déplace